i am uh very excited for anyone who
doesn't know this is the latest demo
for resident evil anyone who's on um
resident evil village or resident evil 8
that is anyone who's on playstation 4
playstation 5 gets it early we have it
for the next 24 hours but it's only 30
minutes
so i think my plan here
uh is frankly i'll probably play it
the same way that uh i maybe always
would for this kind of content which is
i'm not gonna like spend a ton of time
looking for
collectibles or looking for clues i'm
probably gonna spend a ton of time being
afraid
essentially i'm going to play this
organically just the way that i normally
would i'm not gonna you know
try to give you guys a proper demo walk
through i'm just gonna let myself be
terrified because
while uh survival horror is my favorite
genre of video game
and i love horror games i'm a big old
scaredy cat
so that's what's gonna happen um
i don't wanna press play because then i
know that i'm committed
to 30 minutes and i'm nervous about it
i have it for eight hours thank you for
noting that so it's eight hours and then
again on
next saturday so i'll do it next
saturday as well i might do my lady d
cosplay
uh for next week when i have a little
bit more time but for this
let's hit play shall we
oh boy
at least it's daytime that feels good
i need to change my audio uh
sound sound source there we go
beautiful
okay
cool i'm going to add subtitles on i
want to do someone said
something about my stream is mission
crucial parts because they're taking it
slow and the timer's ending for them
okay
well i'm just gonna i'm just gonna play
it organically okay it's gonna be fine
uh make sure you guys can hear this it
seems okay
yes what if we just
made that a bit brighter
honestly that was perfect nope i'm not
changing it even i can't see that i get
to make this one brighter
there
yes okay this better not cut it in my 30
minutes yes
so this one is the village demo
obviously next week playstation users
get the
castle demo um
oh there's the timer it's right there
okay let's go let's go let's go let's go
yep yep yep okay wait wait does that
mean that if i
die i have to go right back to the start
in life and in death we give
glory uh hello
can you guys audio levels okay it's not
safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's me hey the child's [ __ ]
do i look like am i doing it hey wait do
you mean rose
is she here rose rolls
she's a babe she is in great danger
since mother miranda brought her to the
village we have fallen into
darkness what are you talking about the
monsters
my face looks really impressive
the castle bell heralds danger
they're coming no wait what's funny
where's rose
what are you laughing at mother miranda
yeah i do want to know about mother
miranda i'm curious about this
again thank you for letting me know the
video it's good they made a lot of notes
of that so
during the demo it felt like
showcase my words are broken okay well i
see now i don't again okay i'm just
gonna play through it organically it's
fine the game comes out what may 7th
i'm gonna play the whole game you know
so it's not like i need to play this in
any
particular way that's oh i didn't expect
that to open
it looks really good and again i'm
playing with probably more
brightness than uh i should be
love kim fluid love that for me
oh great like um oh great
lichens the failed monsters wolves
the fabled monster wolves of old may
they come to eat our flesh may they come
to tear us apart
what if they didn't be pretty sick if
they didn't
what are you okay whatever um
sick this is bigger than my apartment
all right cool nothing so far
everything's fine everything's fine
nice figures are alpha you're right
i i feel like um i can see there being
some re4 vibes
but i feel like for the most part this
one's really visually distinct i i
mentioned this again in my
showcase video but oh so many options
[ __ ]
well i know what yellow does that's
gonna require a knife
generally oh it needs a crank um
i really like that it looks very
different to
all of the other resident evils no
not that much but but to the extent that
i didn't think that it was resident evil
when we first saw gameplay
okay
well i'm not scared yet so that seems
like a positive
i am running
goat we offer these goats of warding to
protect
the village and its people anyhow break
them shall feel mother miranda's wrath
i mean
you know
what if i want to what if she's also hot
get mad at me baby okay
it's just a graveyard that's chill
that's cool it's fine this is actually a
beautiful village
it's a really nice looking place okay i
see you have two items you want me to
put in there and i don't have them yet
i understand you resident evil i know
what you're about
i feel great about this one this one
this one feels a bit off
just in case
okay no it's fine it's fine it's fine
i think it looks very good
okay so that's one for the door
um that's
just keep going through this path then i
think
okay
well that's lady d is that gonna be
mother miranda maybe
wouldn't have expected it but
uh yes very intentionally playing with a
lot of brightness victor
okay um
i think i'm just another another crank
needed for this
i think i'm gonna go put this on the
door
assuming i can get back out
just to get it done with you know okay
probably wrong but
at least it's here yeah that's gonna be
the other one oh no
there you go cool
sweet making it happen
um okay i don't know that this is the
right way for
where that map was
did i not pick the math up
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh
okay sixth winged being
i'm not that i'd call that a b but all
right
okay okay okay okay okay
uh i don't know if we see tall lady in
this in this uh
demo but i also if anyone does know
please don't spoil that for me
i wonder if i have to go oh that's
spooky back this way for the
you know just nervous etc
look like ammo box was actually just a
tombstone
no i don't have [ __ ] okay we gotta go
back
i don't like any of this
this is that's maybe the house on the
map
it looked big
flies music happening nothing's happened
oh
why do i need cover
people made fun of me when i played the
last ever covering too much or for
crouching too much
okay um it's because it makes me feel
safe okay
oh god oh god oh god oh god
no you don't we're just
just gonna leave me be cause you know
this doesn't feel good this doesn't feel
good it doesn't it doesn't it feels bad
aim it what i can't see anything to aim
at
i feel like maybe crouching is a bad
idea
are you right there then you write you
literally right there
or nah or is that
oh i just see i see it
it's sort of humanoid very outlast vibes
here i would really like to not
die can i climb yes okay
we still have those flower bags to cover
if needed
this is [ __ ] dark
great i love rusted scrap
do you love shotgun am i fan of that
i just i don't know if
this is scripted or if there are stealth
mechanics like i assume there are
stealth mechanics because there are
flower bags which means that i can
actually get through this without
alerting the bad guys i think
is what that means if there's if there's
an option for me to evade them
then i can also probably avoid them
i don't think i'm gonna be able to climb
over this here though am i
no i think i gotta go back around okay
how close are you bud
nope nobody heard anything
um okay
i think i have to go across this side
which is right where it is
so i don't love that for me
are you like right there
uh yeah i'm not reading chat enough for
you guys to spoil it for me
i think i'm trying to look but not too
much because i don't
i don't want any backseating and i don't
want any spoilers
i'm happy to like i said play it
organically as i would you know
just playing it the same way i would if
i weren't streaming pretty much
um sorry if that's not entertaining but
that's what i'm gonna do
you're you're right there huh
that's cool i'm just gonna pass through
wyatt [ __ ] [ __ ] off
nope that didn't that didn't work i know
it didn't work where was the thing i had
to pick up it was like right here
[ __ ] you dude i don't have any [ __ ]
ammo though
i don't think this is gonna work no no
it's not
where was the thing here it was just
rusted scrap
son of a [ __ ]
and i i don't know if okay we're gonna
we're gonna run away
we're gonna run away it's not it's not
gonna go according to plan
um he's maybe too strong i don't know
but i'm not scared of him so
so that seems good
okay
oh
oh that's oh well okay keep moving it is
barricade doorways that's interesting um
but still no
i recognize that you might attack me my
health is probably on like yellow
oh no oh [ __ ] this feels like outlast
uh y'all are too strong and i want no
part in it good day
[ __ ] i said good day i'd love to
i think they could maybe get through
that wooden door though
i don't know i think they'd be fine
stay back please don't hurt us
whoa it's okay i'm not gonna hurt you
i'm just glad to see normal people at
last have you seen any other survivors
no they're all in louise's house which i
think is where i'm going he's not
answering in the gate is locked
quiet girl he's an outsider
but i'm nice i'm real nice
[ __ ] we're setting ducks in here can
your old man walk
no one of the monsters cut him
he's lost a lot of blood we have to get
into louise's house
quiet there must be a way inside
stay here be quiet and don't move until
i get those gates open
okay opening
glad they couldn't get through this
flimsy door
sorry i just opened that that's my bad
i'm really sorry about what i just did
to the door
uh my apologies for that okay
but you got any [ __ ] in here for me
though because i ran out of shotgun ammo
real quick
it's not good it's not good
okay
that's interesting
i can climb up on rooms huh okay cool i
probably have to go up there but i'm
just going to see if there's anything
else
around here beautiful
just in case
still nothing need a crank i wonder
what's in those wells that's so good
okay that's gonna be louise's house
this feels like it's gonna be a bad time
cool okay
that's a good question uh how the
story's gonna tie into bioweapons and
umbrella i'm sure they will
um but yeah i can't imagine how at this
point
uh i did change the camera back to the
logitech chief
um because i'm having this issue where
the razer keyer pro freezes but they did
just
what i have nothing to use on this
probably open it by removing a screw
okay
that's gonna be a screwdriver um they
did just
do a firmware update so i just need to
update it
i just have to open the gate right
what could go wrong yep
come on it's clear this isn't gonna go
well hurry i don't feel like this is
gonna go very well
took your damn time did i though i feel
like i was pretty quick actually you
complete [ __ ] stranger
yeah all right i only have 30 minutes to
do this so i feel like i was a lot
faster than i might normally be he's not
used to relying on other people
busting a chat yelling open main gate
after i did it we'll be safe in here
you're on a delay
see if we're here then out there that's
for sure
hey do you know anything about what's
going on around here
it doesn't make any sense mother miranda
has i would love to know him
i don't know that going inside is really
gonna help him that much but
hey i'll give it a shot
hello anybody home
maybe a familiar voice louisa
open up it's me elena worried that that
would be a jump scare
stop shouting you'll draw the monsters
who's this a friend stay back father
for god's sake julian let us in no
they'll smell the blood you'll endanger
us all
my father will die out here that's not
my problem
what's going on these people want to let
a dying man into our home
come now these people are our friends is
this mother go on go inside
she seems nice this way that's not
expected
you're not from this village ah
no i'm ethan julian go make yourself
useful and check the ground julian
interesting name i said go
hmm
if elena trusts you then so do i
come inside ethan okay
so what are we gonna do when the man
turns wait here
i'll check on the others cool do you
have any [ __ ] i can steal what's this
i'm gonna read your note
louisa they broke in again got more of
the livestock i don't think we'll make
it through the winter at this rate
ernest is still missing two we can't
find him anywhere has mother miranda
oh no she's louisa i think right
not mother miranda
cool
nice
all right anyway cool pictures of your
own town
um do you have any [ __ ] i can steal it's
sort of my thing
i don't feel like i should be nervous
here but also it's resident evil
so i am
come inside the others are waiting this
all seems relatively chill
what the [ __ ] is this outsiders you're
gonna get us all killed
anton he helped leonardo and elena
classic antoine
you know ourselves please ethan take a
seat
you're just always being rude is this
all that's left
from your entire village all that's left
all that's left there is no one left
a worthless invalid
a stupid whaling [ __ ]
and you you drag a bloody man and an
outsider in here like it's nothing and
expect to be all safe
there is no safe every
sorry bastard out there has been ripped
in half
but tomorrow
yeah tomorrow we'll all be dead here
just like a damn husband the
i don't know roxanne i feel like crying
about your dead husband is fair
maybe not listening to generations and
drunk or not
you are all welcome and safe in here
she's gonna die for sure she's much too
nice
this isn't gonna last can someone please
tell me what the hell is going on here
we don't know one day we were a quiet
devout village in the next the monster
screen
and attacked us animation is very good
the
the
that's definitely mocap i would think
it's a good performance where is your
husband
did they no no he he is out there
somewhere he
yes yes that's that's it he he went to
fetch help
let us pray for him
for all of us good idea
come yeah so i feel like this demo is
maybe more story focused than how long
have i been going for
i'm live for 20 minutes
did i rush through it too much now i'm
part of the anxiety is
something that's gonna happen no this
never goes well in a video game
never goes well we call on thee within
the endless dark
to deliver us into faith's hands
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings so we make our sacrifice
at the end in life
and in death we give you glory
mother miranda
no the tea should be ready come help me
elena please
uh devin i can person saying i've heard
it before stream one of the platforms
graveyard i'll be streaming on twitch
later
some [ __ ] as crazy as a bag of rats
there is wisdom in her devotion though
and i hope i like this lady and now i'm
worried about
big her vibes indeed that's pandering to
big cult
what are you doing leonardo okay wrong
are you okay
i did suspect
what did i just say about the nice lady
what did i just say
father elena don't stay back no let me
go
[Applause]
she had it coming man that's what you
get for being
these guys seem too strong sort of my
problem
i don't know if i'm supposed to shoot
them but i don't know that the demo is
the right time to figure that out
later i said
no well that
right in the knee that worked elena oh
my god i'm so sorry father
hey hey that wasn't your father anymore
you did the right thing
[Applause]
elena elena no that's video games but
you can't go back this way by the way
it's so specifically oh hey just letting
you know
you cannot walk back down this hallway
we're gonna shut the door on it also
just so you're awake none of it's
happening leave me alone
no we're getting out of here together
is this where jack shows up and we have
a boss fight in the car again
because that was sick i did really enjoy
that game
bio has it um okay things
you got you got any things for me do we
have
any things nothing
okay okay
okay well i gotta find a way to get out
of the hose here
a lot of noises god look how much
attention to detail there is
look at all this all these assets
look at all this art oh my gosh
sick thanks resident evil oh what is no
just coffee mugs
are these all going to be empty you
[ __ ] use some of them
capcom
okay oh that's hubs no
okay no nothing all right cool
what's how about this yes
the truck key are we sure that i need to
examine this item
oh oh we do okay
okay great
thank you
yes i will take the shotgun ammo and
that's gonna be
it
because the house is on fire or is
somebody coming to do murder
damn the fire's moving fast
get in truck
let's go
what are you thinking uh we drive the
[ __ ] out of here we can bust out with
this
oh i thought that we were gonna reverse
this oh okay we're driving right through
the brick wall
skip slash photo mode huh that's
exciting
let me back up again the fire there
isn't any time
good looking fire though
[Music]
jack's in the back how does the gameplay
feel
um feels really good so far
nothing unusual
it's very similar to biohazard
let's move don't worry
and try not to breathe in the smoke i
know
thank you ethan you're
kind i hope your family how is that not
i do too uh-huh once we get out here
maybe you'll get to meet them
okay well you keep going up
that'd be good just as the saying goes
smoke rises so
you better go up
what's the pla the house is just gonna
fall apart none of this seems like a
good plan
i don't support any of this plan elena
what then you're probably smarter than
me
full of monsters it's true we can't
fight them there's too many
hey hey don't talk like that we'll find
a safe house to put you in until i can
find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
that place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're my health is also like some
real hot chicken that wouldn't that's
not him
he said my name blood wait it's not safe
big titty vampire lady
also it's prettier
come on give me your hand
ethan go save your daughter
don't give up you could for sure have
made it reach for me
a huge bummer l's all round
[ __ ] why is everyone dying on me
i don't know you just try to take her up
the burning house ethan i feel like
maybe
you should take a little bit of
responsibility for what just happened
there
you know you couldn't have kicked you
couldn't have just removed some of those
wooden planks you couldn't
use the screwdriver take the screws out
i feel like we had options that is all
i'm going to say i just
don't get it yeah well maybe if you
thought for a second
ethan you'd [ __ ] get it you big dumb
idiot
don't go up a burning house
jesus christ this place is going back
yeah no
why the [ __ ] is this happening again
yeah i'm not sure about that actually
that probably didn't do that
okay well we have the screwdriver so now
we can get out
that front gate i think that dad's
probably still alive
worth noting um screwed i don't know
it'll tell me when i get there
hello yes
ah it's the other piece
that's [ __ ] up okay so
no okay oh
that mother miranda
who was what was i think it might have
been mother miranda ethan
you you big dummy spell everything out
for this guy
did the truck move
yes
i think maybe no no it's there
okay well we do have to go back that way
so
i guess we'll just i'm running out of
time
i'm running out of time
i don't feel like she'd be a random
encounter is what i'm gonna say
what's up with that though am i supposed
to walk past you or not
yeah yes
death has visited
you leave it on such an interesting pot
damn it so close
uh well i guess that's it yeah i i know
that like in theory i could make another
account to play more of it or whatever
but i don't think i'm going to do that
i'm going to leave it at this
uh because i really you know and
obviously i'll play it next weekend for
the the ps5 uh the
castle demo which i expect to have lady
d in it which is very
exciting obviously um but i'm not gonna
like
explore it too much more than that or
like watch anyone else's playthrough so
that when i actually play
the game it's fresh
um i didn't find that particularly scary
some
some interesting story content there but
i was not into that as
into that as i was into the other demo
um
but you know it's just a demo and
they've been giving us lots of content
and i really appreciate that they're
giving us demos at all that's awesome so
very close to the end that's as far as
we got um
so yeah i am now twitch partnered so i'm
gonna go jump over to twitch probably
give myself like 10 minutes
have something to eat and then i'll i'll
start streaming on twitch
uh for a few hours this afternoon um
yeah can't stream on both simultaneously
anymore since i partnered but i will see
you all there thank you for joining me
not much after just open the gate and
exit the area okay so i was pretty close
sounds like it
yeah uh thank you for joining me
everyone i'll see you next week
same time 5 p.m hopefully um
for the castle demo and i think i'll
probably do my lady cosplay again
that's it all right
goodbye